I'm not saying these are solutions that
everyone's going to like no no I am
saying that your fire simple solution
Aaron teed with this one spoilered don't
have sex the top five guaranteed simple
solutions up to the world slash left's
biggest problems today so question of
the day before we move forward this
topic today's progress is often argue
from a position of nuance we hear that a
lot when I think some things there are
some issues yes that are nuanced they're
more complex but a lot of things a lot
of pivotal issues that we do have pretty
simplistic answers let me ask you what
percentage of major issues would you say
our nuanced and hard to understand
require degree versus having a simple
answer put a percentage on it I'd like
to I think it's about 6040 I think about
60 is a lot simpler than people want to
admit forty percent people maybe need to
learn a little more and read up on it so
number five the problem aids right this
was from the left they said it was
Kyle's complicated you should have
pamphlets and protocols and I said well
listen this is aids and if someone has a
kind of that came to my school someone
has a cut on their finger just don't go
near them and make sure that you know
you could be transferred by kissing and
we don't know it well I think it was
Oprah said one in five people by 1995
would have a let's hear what they said
to date over thirty nine million people
have died of the acquired
immunodeficiency syndrome current drug
therapies mean it's now possible to live
a normal lifespan with HIV but that is
expensive and not a long-term solution
what we really need is an HIV vaccine
and a cure so how close are we I heard
those vaccines make you [ __ ] you
expensive hobby too but people get over
hazy solution how do you not get your
statistical risk factor of getting AIDS
in the United States is zero if you are
not having unprotected gay sex with
strangers and shooting you know how do
you not get in solution stop having
eight soms
number for a problem unplanned
pregnancies it's political football this
is a Hobby Lobby yeah every time they
get in so much trouble for this is the
thing that they tell us the world is
this is nuanced it's known at the world
a place you can't control things happen
that are unplanned and in the
psychological ramifications for the for
the mother when an unplanned in the deal
what's giving up an adoption in Barack
Obama said he even said that he didn't
want his daughter to be punished with a
baby for an unplanned pregnancy so we
need planned parent tax payer funded
birth control and then by the way you
complain about abortions if you really
need taxpayer funded healthcare across
the board along with education and along
with healthcare because because if you
really cared about unplanned pregnancies
you would fund all of the things because
you're not pro-life you're just pro
birth in Washington some politicians are
trying to defund Planned Parenthood but
what does that really mean millions of
people come to Planned Parenthood for
health care services like birth control
STD tests cancer screenings and sex
education by the way schools aren't
doing that have smears yes never had a
mammogram machine for people who don't
know they slip it in there at a time
like people think well breast cancer no
no no they've never had a mammogram so
what's the solution to unplanned
pregnancies by the way I need to clarify
here I'm not saying these are solutions
that everyone's going to like no no I'm
saying surefire simple solution aren t
do this one spoilered don't have sex
number three a big problem right now for
some reason with our generation freedom
of speech just here Vox tell you about
it Twitter's harassment problem is out
of control and it's changing the way we
talk about free speech on the Internet
it's changing the way you talk about
free speech Internet this one's yes with
your Lisp by the way see number five
[Music]
solution
pro tip shut it off you don't need new
algorithms the whole fake news argument
because in fact they cost you less what
you done here everybody used to say this
when when that actually I do realize
this was spearheaded by tipper gore with
the video game ratings a lot that Lobby
that was just the Christian Right but it
was actually everyone at that point
where they were trying to ban all the
things I think Joe Rogan's had nerfed
the world right and they need to say to
content like it shut it off
what's the same thing here do you have
more control than ever just shut it off
by the way if you're talking about
social media and not shutting them off
hit the notifications anything
apparently on YouTube or join mug club
that's where it's $99 ear six and for
students veteran active military get to
watch the show every single day a full
hour otherwise enjoy the livestream
Thursdays at 8 p.m. number two this is a
problem here let transgenderism this is
one that today this is growth this is
really a solution in search of a problem
so you hear this all the time right it's
like okay well homicide suicide is
through the roof from there
complications with gender dysphoria when
you change the dsm-5 the viola you know
it literally tries to close the wound
after a secretary of reassignment
surgery and it's very nuanced this whole
thing is very notes along with hormone
replacement therapy you know it could be
developing cancer because you're
injecting estrogen directly into your
ass and we don't know the long-term
ramifications
okay what's the solution you're a man
you're a woman
but that's the solution accepting
reality the real problem with
transgenderism is that we weren't we
didn't have the balls to tell people the
truth in the first place they don't
either can say no pending weighing some
of them have for look it depends on if
they're pre-op or post-op okay yeah no
we just didn't have and we weren't
compassionate enough to tell them the
truth in love and say hey look this is a
mental thing like you've got it you
can't you can't go this route and yeah I
feel like liberals also open the door
and now everybody is walking and people
are gonna say you're making gross
generalizations here yep yeah and just
so you know people I see everyone is it
aren't you conservative don't you see
everyone as individuals of course I see
people as individuals but we are talking
about the isms here yeah leftism
liberalism progressivism and
conservatism libertarianism federalism
Constitution so so I'm not saying all
people of course anyone who sits in a
guest chair and going to judge as an
individual people's try to do this with
gotchas and I've seen that a liberal
shows like well I thought you see those
individuals oh no listen listen we're
making generalizations about an ideology
just like if I talk about communism I'm
not saying every single person who lived
in Soviet Russia I'm talking about the
Communist Party it's okay it's an
ideology and the number one problem of
course brings us to I guess that you're
not gonna like this but these are the
surefire solutions there's no it's not
up for debate climate change all right
so what are the carbon emissions right
they're increasing the co2 is building
up in the atmosphere and there's a
little hole but then it's kind of
closing the greenhouse gases they're
building up and we're killing off the
planet just to build my tell you very
likely caused by human activities that
means you mean and since the Industrial
Revolution be not a capital way humans
built airplanes faster cars developed
remarkable technology and learned how
the Navigator surrenders he used for our
benefit although this has led to many
wonderful inventions and advancements
like the device you're using to watch
this video or the ability to take a
plane halfway around the world
it also means we have increased our
consumption of natural resources and in
turn released a lot of greenhouse gases
into the atmosphere
I think Brautigan that we're going to
fix that
host we're letting stay yes welcome hi -
oh I know you're about to secrets were
talking he's saying the exact same thing
that we're saying only to him it's a
nightmare yeah he's gonna let me say the
exact same thing in that time we've
created planes and electricity and the
polio vaccine refrigerator your lifespan
and your mom doesn't have to die now
because of a head cold or because
someone got the flu and you'll have to
have nine children because four would
get kicked by a horse because of modern
transportation no I was there at the
kånken clamat summit when I remember Ted
Turner was there and he was talking
about enforcing China's one-child policy
the Kyoto Protocol then became the Paris
Accord there is no law on the books
right now you cannot even find people
who advocate for these laws that can
show you any completely verifiable
discernible effect that they would have
on global climate change you think
China's gonna play by the book we can't
control what the rest of the world does
but again I'm not talking about climate
change whether you agree on the
catastrophic man-made climate change or
not I am talking about climate change
let's accept at point-blank okay it's a
problem what's the solution you heard
bill there's only one kill all the
people usually this is the point where I
would tell you to subscribe or hit the
notification bell up there because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot on
YouTube but if you've been signed up now
at lotto with credit calm slash mug club
for all the daily content to support us
there's probably there's not a pitch I
can make here that'll work so let me
just tell you this I have a cat in my
basement right now if you don't
subscribe at ladder with CARICOM slash
mug club to support this content I am
going to kill him if you don't subscribe
this cat in my basement will die